while Lady Gaga hit the SNL stage pal
Bradley Cooper was lending his support
backstage the pair will co-star in the
upcoming a star is born' remake which
Bradley is also directing but the newly
single Gaga tells Howard Stern she's not
looking for love on the set do you think
a true romance could have come out of
this I'm thinking maybe absolutely no
way no you know as well as I do as an
actor you can fall in love so easily on
this set you know it but I already you
know the thing is is that I already love
everyone you know and the idea is if you
really love somebody you you put the
most important thing first and that is
the film and the truth is what's most
important to me is that we tell a story
that touches the hearts of millions of
people that come to see
Gaga admitted to bursting into tears
after this emotional performance but
guess who was waiting in the wings I
walked off and Bradley was right there
and dave chappelle was the business
there with them and it was just kind of
really sweet they both gave me a big hug
and they were like you did it